[Musik]
und ein Adresse
vorbereitet aber auf alles gefasst das
ist Mona mittendrin
der Verein Aurora bringt betroffene
Familie ich lerne Sabine und Michael
genau
[Musik]
aber über Tabus soll man reden ich kann
als erstes Sandra und ihre drei
[Musik]
dass man es Grab im Vorgarten hat das
ist nicht nur nein
das möchte
verschiedene Diagnose aus anderen
ist das jetzt sehr
sandra hat Note
was mir gerade auffällt
vom Papa
gemacht
[Musik]
brauchen
okay ja
pschte Erinnerungsstück im Zimmer
du Papi schaut jetzt Rudi das wirklich
[Musik]
und gleichzeitig hast
du bist verantwortlich
am Anfang ist er genauso da muss ich
alles Neue organisieren oder also ich
meine es fällt auch für die end also
zurückschreiben
was wünschst du dir für euch Familie
gemacht
für Mama
dass du
Person finde ich dass du glücklich hast
sie mit der Person zusammen
es berührt mich sehr wie ihr befolgt
zueinander
[Musik]
bleibt
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
mit dem habe ich ihn kennengelernt schon
existiert und dann ist die Expedition
sie ihr endet
ich stelle mir das so schlimm vor aber
der Moment wo man erfahrt technischer
abgestürzt oder was passiert
ist passiert
ich bin im Gang stand
jedem und Jedi geht mit dem Verlust
anderst
segnet weil es nicht witzige sondern wir
weil das Gefühl hat dass sie die Person
überfordere mit dem weil viel Wissen
die blöde Situation bringen
du hast die Sniper wirklich
aufs Spiel gesetzt ja aber auch da hilft
eigentlich
die hätte extrem geholfen die schon
wichtig dass die ruhig
in Vergebung und wenn ich die
unterdrückt hätte hätte
Truhe
und ich finde sie wertvoll
meine du weißt im Papa hätte bis
gefährlich gemacht ihr sind noch nie
gesehen er hat trotzdem gemacht
die Zeit heilt alle Wunden stimmt da
hinten läuft
froh dass es so alles so wie sie ist so
leicht gemacht hat
dass man da wohne nicht Liebe sind meine
Kollegen
[Musik]
Schöftland Kanton Aargau
mehr Generationenhaus
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
vorstellen
du musst ganz ganz viel administratives
erledigen und eigentlich überhaupt
für Kinder einigermaßen
[Musik]
machst du da wie offen bist du
Kind alles so wahrheitsgetreu wie
möglich zu erklären
verzählt das im Himmel vielleicht so
ganz viele Länder sind wo man einfach
Fotos
aus dem glücklichen
will mir als geschoren haben
will mir gesagt haben
also
versprochen und am Schluss
[Musik]
die einzige Möglichkeit
ich glaube das würde ich immer wieder
mittragen
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs zum Michael am neuen
Partner von der Silvia de erzählen mit
seiner Tochter Jenny ein Wohnwagen auf
dem Campingplatz salavaux am Montag
sehen hallo hallo hallo
[Musik]
dass man wirklich das aus dass das alles
weg ist
überleistet
also
Panik kann
wirklich Angst gehabt
aber grundsätzlich geht es mir
besser raus
also
[Musik]
das wichtigste ganz wichtig
das nehme ich mit und das ein offenen
Umgang mit der Truhe
[Musik]